sur la question du brassard alors moi
j'exerce en tenue d'uniforme comme je
voulais dit l'observateur peut être en
tenue civile et accompagnés des
policiers en uniforme
dans ce cadre là dans ce cadre là même
si effectivement d'un point de vue
réglementaire
ça ça peut soulever une difficulté mais
à partir du moment où l'observateur va
être tout le temps avec moi si je suis
amené à passer des barrages moi je les
passerai il faut pas que l'observateur
soient bloqués il faut qu'ils puissent
être identifiés comme appartenant aux
professionnels de l'ordre public donc là
aussi il n'est pas choquant que ce
brassard soient prêtés dans ce cas comme
moi je travaillais en uniforme je prête
m'embrasse à l'observateur n'a pas le
brassard toute la journée au brun il l'a
uniquement et moi c'est ce que je lui
demande souvent il ne sort que pour
passer un éventuel mariage police ou
coupe pour est identifié par les
fonctionnaires des compagnies
républicaines de sécurité qui soit à mes
côtés puisque les fonctionnaires des crs
ou des gendarmes mobiles d'ailleurs avec
lesquels je peux est amené à travailler
ont aussi comme fonction de protéger
l'autorité civile pour que je ne sois
pas blessé donc s'il ya quelqu'un qui en
civil à côté ça peut poser une
difficulté qu'il faut qu'ils soient
identifiables dans ce cadre là le
brassard c'est une possibilité